[Music]
in got cotton ooze oh do it wad though
permitted by the Guatemalan panda bear
oh that's a koala
a husband divorced his wife after seeing
her with another man on Google Maps what
I saw him like seems him like the image
did bring walking in the window oh of
his house they look what was he looking
at his house no this happened in Peru
I was looking he was researching the
best way to reach this popular bridge in
Lima and he spotted a familiar figure on
Google Streetview photos and it shows
this right I was like wait a minute kind
of like I can't see [ __ ]
yeah you came as here whoa yeah so then
when you know your wife and you see her
and like this like an intimate moment
with this other one she was just picking
his ear recognized her like that because
she she wears this outfit often Oh
[ __ ] cartoon character Google
automatically blurs the feet oh it just
he could tell that it was her though Wow
wearing the same outfit for like years
cuz the Google Maps like souls they are
old so I could have been before they
were together no it was during their
marriage so these photos were taken in
2013 and so the man angrily confronted
the wife about you know what that was
you idiot
no she actually confessed having an
affair well not anymore that was then
baby yes but we are broken up because he
is [ __ ] some other girl now
yeah I caught him on Google Maps yeah
yeah and so he ended up divorcing her
because of the infidelity
whoo how would that make you guys do so
let's say like [ __ ] seven years later
you find out that there was something
would you feel just as angry yeah cuz it
happens to be married for that long - I
don't know anyone who wouldn't and how
could you sleep at night like knowing
every night for seven years depends on
how successful I am that's true if I'm
happy as [ __ ] right now like my movie
just did well and I just find out this
[ __ ] I'm like I'll get mad next year
I'll be like yo life is [ __ ] good
right now and when life is good
I'm just like burial swallow this one
people died oh let's take one for the
teacher happens I'm not gonna I don't
really get these moments that much so I
gotta take it you know to mean I'm
thinking this like okay cuz now I'm
thinking about situational it's like
let's say they have like four kids or
whatever whatnot would you still yes I
would have to know what that situation
feels like first I know that's kind of
tough cuz even if that thing was like in
the past but it was wild she was with me
and he hid it from me that betrayal and
then no one else if I was suspicious of
him at the time and then he like made me
feel crappy feel like gaslighted you for
like three years about it and then you
find out that would be different than
you just kind of never knowing and then
it just exactly later it comes out it's
kind of like well that's how much
psychological damage was done back then
exactly because I don't like the feeling
of I knew it [ __ ] yeah you know
but if you just didn't know and you
never suspect in your life it's almost
man you feel the fast one down that's
almost worse yeah I don't know we're
thinking that you have this life that
you don't have it all and then you find
out that your judgment is completely
wrong like being ignorant finding out
though and then not being inert ignorant
any like I said it depends on my life
yeah if I'm doing bad I'm gonna take out
my anger on you and if I still hope the
same amount of love the whole time I'd
be like boom he was really gonna love me
and having an affair
man is an expert at it yeah Nikki's
purse just went in with garbage husband
at this time Wow I will be very careful
me though like I don't know if I could
move past it cuz I'm a person that like
I really hold on to [ __ ] yeah and
something about God's hold it I am and I
don't know how people let go of things
it's so hard for me but it depends on
what it is yeah so like I don't know if
I would find that out and it's not
happening anymore but then like I find
out about it now like I don't know if I
could ever get over and in like even
with like you had a kid with the person
and everything was okay a kid with
another person look at me I still walked
away yeah but come on that guy of a boy
what that was it okay cuz you didn't
want him in the first place yeah sure
okay what point being she can't forgive
and she's always in the back of her mind
exactly and I can't yeah I couldn't do
that either actually that did happen to
me with an X like we we had like a break
and like in friends or whatever we kind
of split up and in that time I find out
that he [ __ ] some other girl join a
break though Yeah right okay so but then
just knowing that even though he didn't
technically cheat on me but just knowing
that he had already slept with someone
else like in between me like dude
because let's say like not marrying
about somebody else we went on a break
as I could were not break trust me in
that one week I'm not getting any other
[ __ ] no I'm gonna do a lot of sloppy
work you know it wasn't you shouldn't
give him so much credit cuz this dude
was like I little she was 15 oh my god
oh god that's were you 16 I was
somewhere on there yeah and how old was
he he was like there's 13 you [ __ ]
pedophile no he's like 18 19 yeah it's
like was legal and I would forgive you
cuz you would need to be forgiven
yourself no because I know you're horny
why do you say this [ __ ] on video man
you're setting yourself up ruin my
friend I don't know I'm I'm forgiving I
think I am to like I don't know I
wouldn't I guess I don't know if I'm
just jaded or something we've been
through a lot of [ __ ] it wouldn't really
like that wouldn't wreck me that much
you know what I do hold on to you don't
believe in my dreams
that's worse than zero zero she's like
well let's go through the dreams first
you wanted to own a cat farm you want to
on a farm in Champaign you want to make
a suit out of potato chips a suit out of
potato chip business he's like that's
way to build the mud hut now that's a
real dream I told you you could have
that dream it's like it's here on JK
news there's I told you I don't care so
what are the dreams that you haven't
believed in yeah it's funny because it's
actually owning a sugarcane farm every
time another sugarcane drink shop opens
up [ __ ] takes a picture and send it
to me so you're paying for an Stirling's
it confirms to me that my [ __ ] was legit
I was thinking about it but you didn't
do it so sure the funny thing is is this
I guaranteed you laughed because you
thought he was joking yeah you know how
his brain like you guys are still like
boggled by it on a daily basis like I
did not realize that this was a dream
and we got into a massive fight because
I was like
[Music]
it's like the potato chip suits you know
nobody would ever know that's a real
dream of this I'm just saying some
random [ __ ] I'm gonna call it chip on my
shoulder and you're not gonna [ __ ]
believe in it between a joke in a real
knot with you what that's crazy
it can be hard a lot of credit can I
please just get a lot of credit oh you
can get a min right no thank you
I'm taking one for the team no no that
drives I love the way your brain works
so don't change but oh very funny it's
amazing
the dryest delivery maybe every thought
no he's kidding right it's no he's heard
right now I'm like what what's happening
okay after it happens I look back and
I'm like yeah but like that hurt cuz it
was a real dream so he's like you can
suck another dudes dick with you I even
had a sugarcane that I grew it didn't it
grow once again what's the joke like no
but he really thought when he said that
that the sugarcane being grew he really
believed that and then she said no oh
died it was it was one thing like this
and it went like that and then it just
stayed there well you brought it up as a
supporting point to your dream it's
amazing I love it and don't change I'm
gonna make that drink with you guys you
go-go boots well now this is all fuel
for you to actually make a sugarcane
farm your whole laughter yo would you
clear sugarcane business Joe's cane I'm
not gonna laugh at this dream I was
wrong because you clearly thought this
through I thought it was a big job no I
didn't even know I was gonna name it
yeah I just made that up process and the
product is my dream so much thought into
this it means so much to him Joe's cane
it's his dream if you see my folder of
ideas it's in there that's how you know
I picture a spaghetti trampoline on
there so morning mr. Bator name wasn't
close came Anila folder and then the
idea isn't even words to drive seen
enough folder is that a diagonal so I
should see my desk she's serious there's
a manila folder with a Korean on it no I
believe her so I have no pads with a
bunch of ideas with crayon
like pen sorry I use pens and I have a
lot of brainstorms and there are
diagrams there are designs there are
diagrams and
how do we turn this into stand-up it's
really good it's just good I'm gonna
make a lot of [ __ ] money I like this
stuff if you could somehow harness in
this dead I don't know how though I
don't know it's just so different it's a
different style that's why it's that
exists here no but right it's like it's
like is this is an idiot savant
yeah he's accidentally just murdering
this idiot period Saban
[Music]
[Music]